good afternoon my name is emtional Smith
and on behalf of the Center for student
diversity and inclusion we want to
welcome you to our long-awaited
conversation with dr. Carol Anderson I
know for myself it's been great to see
the conversations from this year's dr.
Martin Luther King jr. celebration for
our University to be expanded even more
than we normally have expanded the
conversations but I think in light of
where we are in our world that these are
the types of conversations that should
be continuously in our mind in our
hearts and in our souls but on the
tongues of ourselves as we speak and
talk and interact with one another dr.
King stated that life's most persistent
and urgent question is what are you
doing for others and that is a question
in which I would challenge you all to
think about I think that that is a
question in which every day when you get
up and you do your headspace to act to
meditate which has been a practice that
I have established in my time here at
Carnegie Mellon but that's one of those
questions that I asked myself what am i
doing for others and when I think about
an urgent and persistent narrative dr.
Anderson's conversation today is truly a
conversation in which we need to engage
in as a Carnegie Mellon community as a
Pittsburgh community and definitely one
for our nation it's time I want to take
a moment to introduce one of our student
leaders John Bailey jr. who's a senior
graduating senior mechanical engineers
do that
who was has been one of our conveners or
student convenors for a call to action
Alliance and it's important for John to
be the person today to introduce our
student speaker
because in many ways it's about carrying
the torch forward and in doing that John
Bailey has done that in helping to carry
forth the messaging that call to action
will continue to give and actually help
our campus community create positive
change but also to help ourselves hold
ourselves accountable to that question
of what are we doing for others so at
this time I'm going to ask John Bailey
to come forward John is going to
introduce our our student remarks for
this afternoon following that dr. Joe
Trotter one of my mentors and one of the
pillars of the Kernighan mellon
community will come forward to introduce
dr. Anderson and then at that time it is
all you dr. Anderson know that we will
also have time for Q&A and again I thank
you all for being in this space with me
I hope that you make a connection with
someone new in in the audience today
because really it's about meaningful
engagement and that's one of the first
steps toward the question of what are
you doing for others so at this time I'm
going to encourage John to come forward
I'm gonna step aside finally this will
be my end of my mo k programming for
2020 1718 year and you know what dr.
Anderson I think the timing is actually
so correct and so if it took a little
bit I'm happy that you're here healthy
I'm happy that you're here healthy but
I'm very happy that you've finally
arrived here to our Carnegie Mellon
community thanks again John it's yours
[Applause]
Stingo an old bet all right good
afternoon everybody
as Michelle said my name is John Bailey
jr. I'm a graduating senior in
mechanical engineering from Harlem New
York and I have the distinct privilege
of introducing our student of mark
Speaker Phoebe
foom or Phoebe is an international first
year PhD student in the psychology
department at Carnegie Mellon University
and goes by both the she and they
pronoun series she held from a Ho Chi
Minh City also known as Saigon Vietnam
where motorcycles and the monsoon heat
are the only constant in the quickly
morphing landscape and mindscape of the
city she is a member of a student
activist group on campus called call to
action a happy contributor to the
diversity and inclusion newsletter of
Dietrich College which is called the
garden so if you have a chance please
check that out and can sometimes be
spotted wandering in the direction of
the zebra lounge of College of Fine Arts
trying to get a cup of coffee everybody
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to our student speaker Phoebe
thank you so much it is an honor for me
to be here with you this afternoon for
dr. Carol Anderson's keynote address
since every great speech seems to begin
with a story and I have barely a few
minutes up here I'll just start with a
really short one about how I ended up on
this podium today so a few weeks ago mr.
Neil Smith at the Center for student
diversity and inclusion I had a
conversation and it took her roughly
five minutes to convince me that it was
a good idea for me to share a few words
here now five minutes
is the shortest amount of time anyone
has taken in the past two years to
convince me of anything substantive
including ice cream so props to her but
I said yes before I realize I was
panicking a lot and a huge part of that
panic comes from just my fear of public
speaking I mean what do I see when I
stand behind podium like this in front
of an audience like you and the other
part of that panic comes from me
realizing just the gravity of having
this platform because really does a
queer international student from Vietnam
have anything anything to do with the
legacy of dr. Martin Luther King jr. a
civil rights leader an American Baptist
minister and a political activist as
you're about to find out the answer to
this question is one that abounds with
irony so let's see what kinds of irony
have I discovered on my way to this
podium for one who when it came to the
United States to pursue my undergraduate
education I had to fill out a form at
the beginning of the year to choose my
roommate and through the ethnicity item
on that form we discovered that I am in
fact Asian
funny I know okay I know but you know
there was some discomfort in that in
that rediscovery and I didn't know why I
was there back then but I know now and
it is because the label Asian seems just
a little bit too lose too large for my
Vietnamese history and heritage and
ironically the narratives of ethnic
homogeneity and unity in Vietnam left me
no room and put a veil over my
Vietnamese history and identity until I
was a fish out of the water and so
slowly I had to reconstruct my
understanding of what it means to be a
Vietnamese while living and breathing in
American politics and so as I did that I
got to know a little bit better about
the model minority myth in which certain
groups of immigrants often East Asians
are deemed to be good kind of immigrants
and the gold standard by which other
good should strive I learned that
through tactics such as the model
minority myth the state has had a long
history of pitching oppressed groups of
all stripes against one another so they
cannot unite against the different forms
of injustice inflicted upon them I
learned of the historical perspective of
the United States on the American war in
Vietnam and I now know that as it tore
my country into two it also ripped the
political fabric of this empire apart I
learned about dr. Martin Luther King
Jr's seminal speech at the march on
Washington where he dreamed loudly and
proudly a collective dream of many black
people and if I may add other people of
color to toward desegregation dignity
and equity at some point I began to
suspect that these realizations should
not and need not be restricted within
the bounds of American history and
politics the 2016 American presidential
election was but part of a rising wave
of global authoritarianism
actually it's quite close to my home the
atrocities of police brutality in the
United States mirror the kind of state
violence towards Palestinian youth such
as a hot enemy and here lies my biggest
realization of an irony but all the
facets of my identity even the ones that
I have yet to realize our political that
identities are political even if the
baggage attached differ from context to
context thus far I've spent one third of
my life outside of my birth country
before Carnegie Mellon I received my
undergraduate education in the Boston
area and before that I was on a
scholarship for high school and
Singapore floating around makes it
difficult to grow roots and today I'm
still learning to graft myself better
into the community around me at Carnegie
Mellon I'm part of call to action a
student group whose aim is to amplify
the voices of underrepresented and
underserved individuals and groups at
CMU to bring about social justice and
positive change I am fortunate enough
that many graduate students in my home
department the psychology department are
passionate about reaching out to and
sharing knowledge with students in the
Greater Pittsburgh area and have been
able to join them in some of their
outreach efforts the past seven months
have been a whirlwind and I don't think
that the next four years will slow down
for me in any way but maybe that's what
it should be for if you can't fly then
run if you can't run then walk if you
can't walk then crawl but whatever you
do you have to keep moving forward so
that was a long detour but you know to
return to the original question of
whether I have anything to do with the
legacy of dr. Martin Luther King jr. the
answer as you may have expected is a yes
yes insofar as I should not deem myself
an external party to the community in
which I am in bed
insofar as my words still carry a weight
for the people with whom I speak and my
inaction in the face of injustice
regardless of what form it takes or
where it takes place screens complicity
in so far as being woke is neither an
end goal nor a title to claim for social
currency but a difficult and continuing
process and that I cannot do this alone
insofar as the fight for justice is a
global battle never ending ever
urgent insofar as six days shy of 52
years ago dr. King led a demonstration
of 5,000 protesters in Chicago to decry
the American war in Vietnam
sue me and with a quote from dr. King
speech beyond Vietnam now let us begin
now let us rededicate ourselves to the
long and bitter but beautiful struggle
for a new world this is the calling of
the sons of God and our brothers wait
eagerly for our response shall we say
the odds are too great shall we tell
them the struggle is too hard will our
message be that the forces of American
life militate against their arrival as
fool men and we sent our deepest regrets
or will there be another message of
solidarity with their yearnings of
commitment to their cause whatever the
cost the choice is ours and though we
might prefer it otherwise we must choose
in this crucial moment of human history
thank you for opening your heart and
mind to me today in this auditorium in
memory of dr. Martin Luther King jr.
[Applause]
wow that's amazing I am really happy to
see how the students are involved in
this initiative in this effort but I
must say it is a pleasure to introduce
our speaker professor Carol Anderson but
this is not the first time that curl has
presented at Carnegie Mellon is not even
the second time this is the third time
that Carl is through presenting at
Carnegie Mellon and I might say that be
careful because we might make you our
own okay she came here in 1911 and again
in 1915 and now in 1818 Carol okay I'll
put a 20 on it okay 20 I hate to say
that I flashed back okay to the 20th
punch okay then 2011 and 2015 how's that
oh okay let me get on with it
okay puron is the howard candor
professor of african-american studies at
Emory University in Atlanta her
scholarship and teaching focus on the
impact of public policy on patterns of
race social justice and inequality in
African American and US history in
addition to numerous scholarly essays
and articles she is the author of three
groundbreaking books her first book eyes
off the prize published by Cambridge
University Press
this book examined the african-american
struggle for Human Rights not just civil
rights human rights in the years after
World War two
after prize won both the Gustavus Meyer
and merna merna 'the book awards for
excellence in scholarship she is also
the author of a second book title
bourgeois radicals published by
Cambridge University Press as well this
book builds upon the immense
contributions of her first book boudoir
radicals documents the extensive role of
the n-double a-c-p in the liberation
movements of both africa and asia but
perhaps most important for us today and
this evening for understanding race
class and social justice issues in our
times dr. Anderson is the author of the
best-selling book white rage the
unspoken truth of our racial divide
published by Bloomberg press in 2016
white rage arrived at just the right
time to help us understand the roots of
racial conflict in American society in
the 21st century accolades for white
rage have come in they include the New
York Times best seller on race and civil
rights the one number one best seller on
Amazon discrimination and constitutional
law studies list and the New York Times
editors pick for July 2016
but her Awards do not stop there
professor Anderson's other awards
include a variety of research
fellowships
from such organizations as the National
Humanities Center harvest Charles Warren
Center for studies in American history
and most recently the Posen chair in
human rights at the University of
Chicago I believe to be taken up in 2019
professor Anderson is not only an
outstanding researcher and writer she is
also an excellent teacher in an engaging
public intellectual her teaching awards
are over a half-dozen that I counted on
her CV and in conjunction with other
awards with other scholars they escalate
professor Anderson received her
undergraduate degree and her MA degree
from the University of Miami in Ohio
where she graduated Phi Beta Kappa
she served - she earned her PhD degree
in history from the Ohio State
University her CV is long and I will not
delay her appearance in the Longworth so
let us welcome professor Carol Anderson
thank you wow thank you so much for
being here on a Thursday because I know
there's things to do on a Thursday in
Pittsburgh because this joke has said
I've been here a minute but what I so I
want to thank the diversity initiative
for inviting me I want to thank Joe I
want to thank Carnegie Mellon because
this is my second home I've been here so
long but what I wanted to do was to talk
about how this black woman got to white
rage hmm and it started in February 1999
a black man had been working hard all
day and he came home and he was hungry
you know that feeling when you've been
working hard all day and you just want
something to eat you look in the
refrigerator and it's looking back at
you and and so there's nothing in every
frigerator that he wanted it so he he's
like I'm gonna go get something to eat
but you know what I'm in New York City
the city that never sleeps
I'm gonna go get me something to eat and
so amadou diallo mm-hmm stepped out on
his front porch just to go get something
to eat a car came up four police
officers of the NYPD hopped out guns
drawn and they started firing 41 bullets
later amadou diallo went down 19 of
those bullets hit him
Mamadou was unarmed when you talk to the
police officers they were like see um
like we um
we were looking for a serial rapist yeah
yeah that's it
well did he look like and well no and so
then they went hunting for something on
Amadou
and there was nothing no criminal record
no warrants nothing that would justify
41 bullets that was bad but then there
was Mayor Rudy Giuliani I oh I can tell
this we don't have church up in here
today oh that was some sweet call in
response oh yeah oh yeah it was Rudy
Giuliani and he's being interviewed by
Ted Koppel on ABC's Nightline and Ted
Koppel is no softball interviewer Ted
Koppel comes at you hard Ted Koppel
doesn't layup and Ted Koppel was like a
Madhu o Madhu
i'ma to Rudy's not flinching Rudy says
my policies are working New York City is
safer than it has been in years and I'm
like it wasn't safer Amadou safer for
him and he said my policies are working
now those policies that he talked about
that was broken windows policing and
broken windows policing was a theory
that if what you did was you hyper
policed a neighborhood
so you litter cops are on you you
jaywalk cops are on you that that hyper
policing but you get this hyper policing
in black and brown neighborhoods which
means you get the criminalization of
black and brown people that
criminalization was the policy that he
said was working and as he told Ted
Koppel not only are my policies working
but my police force is the best behaved
and the most restrained in America now
that's where I went into Kafka
you know cuz if Gregor Samsa can be a
cockroach then we know that's a police
force that can put 41 bullets into an
unarmed man can be the most restrained
and best behaved you know you're looking
at a flip of the language that makes no
sense because I was sitting there but I
couldn't put my name put a name on it
you know what do I call this thing all I
know is that something's not right
that's all I knew something's not right
but there's something that's happening
here and so as a scholar I keep writing
I keep researching I keep teaching I
keep writing I keep researching I keep
teaching and then August 2014 happens
I'm in my home office I've got the TV on
and all of a sudden I see Ferguson
Missouri in flames and it didn't matter
what station I had on because I had to
remote my hand and I'm doing this
whether I was listening this on the left
hand whether I'm listening to MSNBC CNN
or Fox
[Applause]
it didn't matter they were all saying
the same thing oh look at black folks
burning up where they live
can you believe the black people are
did you see those black people burning
up with who what is wrong with black
people because America needs the
narrative of black pathology that
there's just something you know America
would be alright if black folks would
just and then you fill in the blank
right
they just valued school the how you'd
education like everybody else does as
you talked about the model minorities
right if they would just vote if they
would just take care of their kids how
am i doing so far anybody hear any of
this
mm-hmm in that narrative of black
mythology as they're talking about this
black rage I found myself shaking my
head I'm like rage that's white rage
whoa like and and I was in a program
called the op-ed project so I started
writing white rage this is white rage
except I didn't type quite like that but
as I'm going through this laying out how
white rage works what begins to hit me
initially is that as a nation we are so
focused in on the flames that we've
missed the kindling kindling yes I knew
this was church kindling I lived in
Missouri for thirteen years taught at
the University of Missouri Columbia and
I saw how that state worked kindling in
Ferguson
the population is about 67 percent
african-american in 2013 in the
municipal election the black voter
turnout rate was 6% how do you turn
sixty seven percent of the population
into six percent of the voters kindling
policies that begin to manipulate
African Americans access to their basic
citizenship rights kindling or let's
take the education Michael Brown came
out of a school system the Ferguson
Schools Missouri has this accreditation
system where you can earn up to a
hundred and forty points for school
systems that's how they're you're
accredited graduation rates
matriculation rates standardized test
scores you know you know the kind of the
usual suspects 140 how many points do
you think that Michael Browns school
system got sixty fifty okay we got a
fifty over here that's a good one
anybody else twenty was there a twenty
two somebody somebody fix I'm out to say
twenty you're like no I'm not saying it
now so we got fifty we've got twenty
somewhere up in here
sixty-six teen did you say sixty okay
okay fifty sixty s 14
for 15 years begin to think about what
that looks like in a school system where
we are sending black children through a
school system that cannot even garner
enough points to get up to failing and
not only did we do it for one year but
we had folks on the school board and the
school administration who were really
cool with the school system that took an
entire generation of black children
through from K 3 12 and wasn't satisfied
then but then took yet another group
because we were talking about 15 years
so we've got another group of children
coming through that system that
systematically assists Emily does not
work in the state kept accrediting it
provisional accreditation provisional
accreditation provisional accreditation
kindling or let's talk about the police
we know that the police are here to
serve and protect serve and protect it's
not so good doesn't and you know what I
love is that we know this it's like it's
in the air it's like our hem book right
it's like what we don't even have to
turn to you know him number 49 because
we just pick it up and we say the police
are here to serve and protect not in
Ferguson the Ferguson Police looked at
that black population as revenue
generators whoo you look like you were
doing 26 and a 25 ticket I don't really
recall you putting on your turn signal
ticket
did you change lanes without signaling
ticket oh that looks like a busted
taillight ticket and the ticketing on
this black population was so intense
because we are talking about a
working-class population so when you get
hit with a series of $50 and $100
tickets I mean you're figuring out
whether you're gonna pay the ticket or
whether you're gonna pay the rent
you're figuring out whether you're gonna
put food on the table
or pay the ticket you know when you're
thinking about choices you're thinking I
got to keep the roof over the head I've
got to keep food on the table I got to
keep the heat on I got to keep the water
on well the next time you get pulled
over for doing 26 and a 25 and you
haven't paid that ticket there is a
warrant out for your arrest so now you
got black folks arrested and then having
to pay all of the fines and the court
costs that go with that it was so
intense that those fines generated 25
percent of the city's operating revenue
yes that would be a two-five
you know I got no sense but worse than
that because you know we still like to
think justice is blind some cynics in
here too but the way that it would work
is if a police officer pulled over
someone white it would be oops sorry you
can go or if the officer happened to
give the ticket when the white person
went to go pay the ticket you don't have
to pay that and would tear it up so you
have justice operating in Ferguson
Missouri in the 21st century that is
openly blatantly racially discriminatory
and predatory kindling and so as I began
to think through the way that white rage
worked it was so it became so clear to
me that it was working its way subtly
corrosive ly quietly legally through the
courts through school boards through the
legislature that it was working so
smoothly that we couldn't see it so I
set out to blow graphite on that
fingerprint of white rage and track it
over history because I am a historian
and to see how this thing moved one of
the things that became clear to me was
that it's not the presence of black
people that triggers white rage that's
almost like what you're talking about
wheelers
it's the presence of black people with
ambition it is the presence it is the
presence of black people who achieve who
aspire yeah it is the black presence of
black people who refuse to accept their
subjugation and black people who demand
their rights it is in that action that
is the trigger for white rage but I've
got to tell you that sounds
counterintuitive because in America this
is the land of opportunity where all you
have to do is work hard I'll tell you
we're in that him though aren't we yeah
you got to work hard keep your nose
clean go to school and you too can have
the mm-hmm so any so this is why this is
counterintuitive because how many times
have you heard if black folks would only
so how is it that white rage is the
trigger for black folks who are doing
only accept then how do you explain how
government after government after
government has systematically denied
black children the right to an education
black parents have been fighting hard
for centuries to gain access to quality
education for their children only to be
rebuffed ticked denied let me give you a
couple of examples in 1947 this would be
after the US had helped defeat the Nazis
in Prince Edward County Virginia
they had finally built finally built a
high school for black kids
because you know we're in Jim Crow
schools so finally a high school for
black kids 1947 by 1951 that school is
bursting at the seams it's got so many
children you got kids on top of kids in
there and have you been in classrooms
where you're on top of each other the
learning stops because all you thinking
oh he's on top of me and so the parents
went to the school board and said our
babies are on top of each other this is
not a quality learning environment we
pay taxes to our babies deserve quality
education school boards enough and the
parents kept coming they would not give
up
finally the school board relents and
puts up three tarpaper shacks it says
there that's where your kids can go into
the tar paper shacks meanwhile the white
schools are made of bricks with indoor
plumbing Barbara John's 17 year old
Barbara John's was an organizer Robert
Jones was like oh not today my name
would be the wrong one and so she
started talking to her classmates you
believe this mess tar paper what we
gonna do about it what we gonna do what
we gonna do and you know that kind of
conversation what we gonna do what we
gonna do another say you start hearing
what we gonna do what we gonna do I know
we're over don't we gonna walk on out of
here we're gonna protest this mess
and so protest they did she organized a
mass walk out of the moat in high school
administrators teachers like who and she
was like yeah
[Music]
but the thing is is that death threats
started raining down on her this 17 year
old child who just wants to be educated
her parents had to sneak her out of
Virginia to safety in Alabama
I'm telling you Lord when you got to go
to Alabama for safety
this is some real deal stuff right I'm
going to Alabama to be free but Prince
Edward County wasn't through because the
black parents and children kept pushing
demanding quality education and so
Prince Edward County when the brown
decision came through Prince Edward
County said I got something real for you
we're gonna shut down the entire school
system yeah because I are smart now what
why they did that because I see the
furrowed brow there it's like we're why
they did that because if the Supreme
Court is saying that the schools have to
be equal right if you don't have a
public school system then it is equal
for black and white children alike but
she's got that look she's got the hand
over the mouth like where am I
welcome to America
and so but you know why parents aren't
having that you know the school board
can ignore black parents but white
parents there used to juice there used
to clout there used to being heard and
in the school board and the state
legislators don't know where we got you
we got you and so what they set up was a
private tuition voucher system paid for
out of the state so that white children
could go to all-white private academies
and continue their education there was
nothing available now understand black
parents are paying taxes so black
parents are paying for white children to
go to all-white private academies paid
for by the state when there is nothing
available for their children
Prince Edward County was closed five
years it took a couple of Supreme Court
decisions to finally open that thing up
but imagine your school shuts down when
you are in the fifth grade it doesn't
open up again until you're in the tenth
what have you lost and this is happening
just at that moment where the US economy
is turning from a manufacturing based
economy to a knowledge based technology
driven economy and we have thousands
upon thousands of black folks just out
of Prince Edward County who cannot be in
that economy schools were shut down in
other places throughout the south and
let's think about this so when Brown
came down in 54 and then the brown
decision Brown - with all deliberate
speed in 55 100 members of Congress
about 101 members of Congress signed a
manifesto promising massive resistance
to Brown so you have US senators and us
congressmen vowing to do everything in
their power to undermine the law of the
land but in 1957 all the sudden there
was the sound this is the beauty of
being at Carnegie Mellon you already
know what that is
and with that you heard Eisenhower
President Eisenhower going dang dang
dang because that was Sputnik the
Soviets had launched a satellite and
what that meant I'm having the
technological ability to get that thing
up in orbit it now meant that their
nuclear arsenal because the US had
gotten a little swag on
yeah they got nukes but they can't get
to us like they can get across the
Pacific or like they can get across the
Atlantic beep this Eisenhower starts
talking about a national security crisis
we need to have the brainpower to fight
the Cold War we need to train enough
scientists and engineers so that the US
will continue to have the technological
ability and superiority to counter
whatever the Soviets do this is the time
when the federal government is talking
about putting via the National Defense
Education Act hundreds of millions of
dollars pouring in to colleges and
universities this is the landmark this
is huge well this bill as it's working
its way through Congress is being
shepherded by the senator in the
congressman from Alabama and they love a
center that hundreds of millions of
dollars in thinking about what that
could mean for Bama mmm but there was
this little problem called brown because
they had dug in with massive resistance
and so they're talking to the Eisenhower
administration now we can Shepherd this
bill through but we we just want to make
sure that we can continue to have access
to those hundreds of millions of dollars
as long as we continue to defy Brown and
keep Alabama an old miss and the
University of Georgia and all of them
whites only admissions and the
Eisenhower administration said yes
that's all right you will not find any
pressure from us to uphold the law of
the land now begin to think about what
that means
where I'm like okay so we've got
national security crisis Jim Crow
nuclear annihilation Jim Crow nuclear
annihilation Jim Crow except in this
matrix of decision-making Jim Crow think
about the millions anybody see hidden
figures yeah yeah think about in this
moment of counterfactual history yeah
yeah right think about what this nation
could have been if we had opened up
those opportunities opened up all of
those resources all of those labs all of
that computing equipment but instead
whites-only
and we live with the legacy of that to
this very day I'm gonna take another one
war on drugs there goes that church
thing again now one of the ways that
white rage works is that it sounds
logical
remember this is cloaked in legislators
and judges and and so the warrant we've
got to keep our community safe you know
we've got to keep our community safe
we've got to protect our children from
the scourge of drugs it sounds logical
except
african-americans do some category of
drugs like marijuana at about the same
rate of whites and cocaine at a much
lower rate so how is it then in this war
on drugs to protect our communities from
the scourge that we have incarcerated
most those who do drugs the least we
have waged war on those who are doing it
the least yeah that's one of those
moments
I've come to scooby-doo moments we are
and to put this another way the US has
spent about 1 trillion dollars on the
war on drugs to incarcerate most those
who do drugs the least and begin to
think about what one trillion can mean 1
trillion for our infrastructure whoo 1
trillion to keep tuition low
oh yeah y'all can sing it now yo y'all
hear y'all feelin it now yeah we have
time you write that check mmm but
imagine if I worked in Ohio at the Ohio
Board of Regents for a while over a
decade and one of our things was trying
to get tuition low by having state
subsidy at a high enough rate so that
the students wouldn't have to pay so
much because you can do it if you if you
elect reallocate your resources instead
what was happening
we have destabilized state budgets by
mass incarceration
we have destabilized black communities
via mass incarceration
we have destabilized families via mass
incarceration
we have destabilized democracy give you
an example Florida now my students laugh
because like when we're talking about
the compromise of 1877 it was because
Florida couldn't figure out how to count
then when we get to the election of 2000
Florida couldn't figure out how to knit
like steel but as I say in the South
bless their hearts and Florida has
massive felony disfranchisement if you
have a felony conviction you cannot vote
in Florida and it's permanent
well almost permanent there is an entire
process you have to go through in order
to get your voting rights back after you
have served your sentence and your
parole after all of the terms of your
sentence are done then you have to wait
14 years to individually petition the
governor to ask him to grant you your
voting rights back what this means in
Florida and when I say felony conviction
I do mean the standard stuff but but
Florida also has things like letting a
helium balloon go up in the air or
walking through a construction site and
I'm like lord help you if you let a
helium balloon go up the air while you
were walking through a construction site
and so what happens then is that in
Florida
40 percent of black adult black men
cannot vote 40 percent overall it's
about 23 to 25 percent of African
Americans cannot vote in Florida now
begin to think about what that looks
like because you know Florida counts
those bodies in the census when it is
figuring out how many representatives is
going to get in Congress
I know this is looking like the 3/5
clause to me where you can count those
bodies but they have absolutely no say
no vote yeah speaking of the vote how
many of you heard after the 2016
election well you know black folks
didn't just they just didn't show
up you know they just weren't filling
Hillary homo raise that hand you know
you heard it that's right
what he just didn't show up this was the
first election in 50 years without the
protection of the Voting Rights Act let
me explain how that happened
in 2008 Barack Obama became president of
the United States a black man in the
White House okay how many got well I'm
not looking at my said mommy you believe
this right it was just one of those what
whoa but how it happened was an
incredible ground game massive
organizing getting out the vote in 2008
15 million new voters showed up at the
polls Wow now generally what we say is
we love a vibrant democracy y'all got
some cynics here at carnegie-mellon I'm
just telling you over there over there
in that corner right over there
we say we love democracy we stand we
think about what it means when you have
people invested in democracy it works
when you have people who are alienated
who feel they have no stake and let's
talk about the demographics of that 15
million to million new african-american
voters came to the polls in 2008 two
million black folk who had not voted
before
two million new Hispanic voters who had
not voted before 600,000 new
asian-american voters and almost
doubling the percentage of people who
made less than $15,000 a year so you've
got black folk you got brown folk you've
got Asians and you have got the poor now
this is a demographic that is saying I
see something valuable in America and I
am going to participate civically we
should be applauding this right this is
great over in the dark bowels
in in 2013 the Supreme Court in Shelby
County v holder gutted the Voting Rights
Act John Roberts and his decision said
that it was basically an artifact of a
bygone era that racism no longer really
existed like that in America that it was
punitive in that it unduly picked on the
South that it was basically calcified
because many of the jurisdictions that
were under the the preclearance doctrine
where if you were going to change
anything in your voting regulations your
voting rules
it had to be okayed by the Department of
Justice preclearance that any of the
districts that were there many of them
are still there so it shows that this
thing is calcified and I'm like it shows
that the folks who were acting a fool in
1965 are acting the fool in 2013 because
the Voting Rights Act had stopped over
700 changes that these districts had
tried to make to their voting rights 700
with the gutting of the Voting Rights
Act now that these districts don't have
to get pre-cleared to be able to change
whatever they want to change they hit it
hard
let's take Alabama remember where
Barbara John's ran for safety in Alabama
in 2011 which is actually two years
before the Shelby County v holder
decision Alabama passed a voter ID law
saying you have to have
government-issued photo ID in order to
vote now the Republicans taped
themselves I don't know somehow
talking and what they said was we have
got to figure out how to decrease the
black voter turnout and because you know
they can't help themselves because these
illiterate and these Aborigines will get
on these hot financed buses to the polls
as they're crafting the law so I'm
thinking this law can't get through the
preclearance of the DOJ but after the
Voting Rights Act gets gutted boom
Alabama immediately implements that law
now in doing so it is identifying what
types of government-issued photo ID
because the part of the way that white
rage works is it looks logical and so
I've had folks say well you know I mean
I've got it I've got to have an ID to
check out a library book how hard can it
be to get an ID anybody hear that before
mm-hmm okay so let's talk about Alabama
so in Alabama Alabama is somewhere
between the 47th to the 48th poorest
state in the nation
Alabama's poor it has a lot of public
housing because Alabama is poor 71
percent of those in public housing are
African Americans Alabama decided that
public housing ID would not count as
government-issued photo ID for voting
now I'm thinking it doesn't get more
government-issued than public housing
but what you can see in that decision
about what types of ID is that you can
begin to start shaping the demographic
of the electorate you can begin to
target that coalition that put Obama
into the White House what the governor
then did was he shut down the Department
of Motor Vehicles in the Black Belt
counties now he did this because this is
some his mistress and this is some crazy
pillow talk
yo baby you know I think you ought to do
shut down the Department of oh yeah baby
and that's what he I mean that's all
y'all got to talk about but that's what
happens I mean you can't make this stuff
up her name is Rebecca by the way and so
in shutting down the Department of Motor
Vehicles in the Black Belt counties and
the Black Belt counties are those
counties in Alabama it really were
supposed to be about the soil but those
are the counties that have large
somewhere between thirty to forty two up
to seventy percent of their population
is african-american those are the Black
Belt counties shut down these for fiscal
reasons
now what happens then is that 15 percent
of african-americans in Alabama do not
have a driver's license four percent of
whites do not and it's really logical
cars are expensive you got the note you
got the gas you got the insurance you've
got the maintenance and you got parking
when you're paying for a car and you're
on because in the black belt counties at
least 25% of the population lives below
the poverty rate in some counties is up
to 40%
you are making keen choices about how
you are spending your very limited
dollars when there's not a Department of
Motor Vehicles in your County how do you
get the card that you need in order to
vote in your County and you don't have
public transportation alabama ranks 48th
in the nation in public transportation
you can't drive there because you don't
have a car you don't have a driver's
license so what you have a fence
basically essentially set up is a mass
of voters who don't have access to their
basic right to vote because of the want
of a card now what we also hear in this
is voter fraud voter for how many of
heard about voter fraud yeah again this
is the mask
Justin Leavitt a law professor in
California did a study from 2000 to 2014
or 15 to identify how many cases of
voter identification frog had in fact
happened out of 1 billion votes he found
31 cases 31 31 this is the massive voter
fraud that has put that it has put the
fig leaf over what is happening with all
of these voter suppression laws that get
Americans to believe that this is about
protecting democracy protecting the
electoral integrity of the ballot box
when in fact what it is about is
suppressing the rights of American
citizens
take Texas I ma'am you like it
[Laughter]
dang y'all first let me hit Wisconsin
quickly because I want to get into the
craziness of these government-issued
photo IDs up until the spring of 2016
Wisconsin would not allow military IDs
as a government-issued photo ID to vote
now if public housing is like
government-issued I'm here to tell you
being part of the military you are
government-issued you know I come daddy
was career military army I get
government issued but Wisconsin denied
the right to vote to members of the
Armed Forces that were that was the ID
that they had until it got too difficult
to wear that little flag lapel pin and
talk about we're denying soldiers the
right to vote that was 2016 Texas you
know we're gonna get there Texas within
two hours of Shelby County v holder
Texas passed SB fourteen their voter ID
law in their voter ID law they
identified the types of ID's that
counted and of course everything else
didn't so student IDs did not count
so government-issued but you're at the
University of Texas Austin you would be
that would be a state-funded school your
government-issued photo ID would not
count but your gun registration permit
would okay this is a great audience
because you can see how selecting the
types of ID begin to shape who the
electorate is who has access to the
ballot box and only one-third of the
counties in Texas actually have a
Department of Motor Vehicles now Texas
did its analysis and figured out
something like 1.6 million of its
residents would need to drive 125 miles
to get to the nearest Department of
Motor Vehicles and then another 125
miles to give it since the 250 mile
round-trip but you know you can't drive
because you don't have a driver's
license sayin and and so in the original
bill there was language about
reimbursement for that 250 mile
round-trip before the bill passed they
drew a line through the reimbursement so
that 250 mile round-trip is on you this
looks like a poll tax it is a way to
suppress the vote and so when you hear
what black folks just didn't show up
the black voter turnout rate in 2016
because of massive voter suppression
Wisconsin North Carolina Texas
Pennsylvania Georgia Alabama Michigan
isn't a southern thing declined by 7
percent declined by 7 percent voter
suppression put Trump in the White House
we need to understand that and all of
this was done all of it what's happening
in our schools was happening in our
criminal justice system was happening
with our voting rights all of this was
done without
clan cross-burning it was done coolly
methodically systematically in
statehouses in the Supreme Court this is
white rage and so what I want to do
right now is just read you a couple of
passages and then open it up for Q&A and
now I got to put my glasses on because
I'm no longer 25 this one comes from the
war on drugs where I start off talking
about laying out Michelle Alexander's
analysis of the Supreme Court decisions
that embedded racism in the operating
code of the law dealing with the war on
drugs taken together those rulings
allowed indeed encouraged the criminal
justice system to run racially amok and
that's exactly what happened on July
23rd 1999 into your Texas in the dead of
night
local police launched a massive raid and
busted a major cocaine trafficking ring
at least that's how it was billed by the
local media which after having been
tipped off lined up to get the best most
humiliating photographs a 46 of the
town's 5,000 residents handcuffed in
pajamas underwear and uncombed hair
being paraded into jail for booking the
local newspaper the tour Sentinel ran
the headline to your streets cleared of
garbage the editorial praised law
enforcement for ridding tewi of
drug-dealing scum bags the raid was the
result of an 18-month investigation by a
man who would be named by Texas Attorney
General as outstanding lawman of the
year
Tom Coleman didn't lead a team of
investigators
instead he single-handedly identified
each member of this massive cocaine
operation and made more than 100
undercover drug purchases he was hailed
as a hero and his testimony immediately
led to 38 of the 46 being convicted with
the other cases just waiting to get into
the clogged court system Joe Moore a pig
farmer was sentenced to 99 years for
selling $200 worth of cocaine
Kizzy white received 25 years while her
husband William cash loved lended 434
years for possessing an ounce of cocaine
the case began to unravel however when
Kizzy sister Tanya went to trial
Coleman swore that she had sold him
drugs
Tanya however had video proof she was at
a bank in Oklahoma City 300 miles away
cashing a check at the very moment he
claimed to have bought cocaine from her
hmm then another defendant Billy Don
wafer had time sheets and his boss's
eyewitness testimony that wafer was at
work and not out selling drugs to
Coleman and when the outstanding lawman
of the Year swore under oath that he had
purchased cocaine from Ewell Bryant of
tall bushy-haired man only to have
Bryant bald and five foot six appear in
court it finally became very clear that
something was awry Coleman in fact had
no proof whatsoever that any of the
alleged drug deals had taken place there
are no audio tapes no photographs no
witnesses
no other police officers present no
fingerprints but his on the bags of
drugs no records over the span of an 18
month investigation
he never wore a wire now he claimed to
have ridden each drug transaction on his
leg but to have washed away the evidence
when he showered okay so I'm going you
know I know I got a pray in church so
I'm gonna go right here with you
so we got two things happening here even
the boy has not taken a shower in 18
months oh he went out bought some drugs
wrote it on his leg went home showered
hang went out bought some drugs wrote it
on his leg went home showered additional
investigation led to no corroborating
proof when the police arrested those 46
people and vigorously searched their
homes and possessions no drugs were
found nor were weapons money
paraphernalia or any other indications
at all that the housewife pig farmer or
anyone else arrested were actually drug
kingpins what was discovered was
judicial misconduct running rampant in
the war on drugs and Tulia Texas with a
clear racial bias Coleman had accused
10% of Toya's black population of
dealing in cocaine based on his word
alone 50% of all of the black men in
town were indicted convicted and
sentenced to prison
Randy critic of the William Moses
counselor fund called Tulia a mass
lynching taken down 50% of the male
adult black population like that it's
outrageous it's like being accused of
raping someone in Indiana in the 1930s
you didn't do it but it doesn't matter
because
bunch of Klansmen on the jury are gonna
string you up anyway
but this wasn't 1930 it was the
beginning of the 21st century with a
powerful civil rights movement that had
bridged those two errors but the war on
drugs really really did its damage to
the Civil Rights Act of 64 and the
Voting Rights Act of 65 as designed the
next piece that I'm going to read deals
with respectability and Barack Obama
black respectability or appropriate
behavior doesn't seem to matter if
anything black achievement black
aspirations and black success are
construed as direct threats Obama's
presidency made that clear aspirations
of their achievement provide no
protection not even to the god-fearing
on June 17th 2015
South Carolinian Dylan roof a white
unemployed 21 year old high school
dropout was on a mission to take his
country back ever since George Zimmerman
had walked out of the courthouse a free
man after killing Trayvon Martin and a
racially polarized nation debated the
verdict roof had looked to understand
the history of America trolling through
the internet he stumbled across the
Council of conservative citizens the
tri-c the progeny of the 1950s white
Citizens Council that had terrorized
black people clothed schools and worked
hand-in-hand with state governments to
defy federal civil rights laws despite
the groups of valve racists belief
system in the mid to the late 1990s the
group boasted of having 34 members who
were in the Mississippi legislature
including then Senate Majority Leader
Trent Lott by 2004 Mississippi Governor
Haley Barbour chair of the Republican
National Committee and 37 other powerful
at
politicians had all attended traicee
events in the 21st century
Aurel hoped the third who was chair of
the tri-c gave $65,000 to Republican
campaign funds in recent years including
donations to the 26th presidential
campaign of Rand Paul Rick Santorum and
Ted Cruz the traicee then enjoyed
precisely the cachet of respectability
that racism requires to achieve its own
goals within American society and its
website of hatred and lies provided the
self-serving education Dylan roof so
desperately craved
he drank in the poison of his message
got into his car drove to Charleston
entered Emanuel AME Church and landed in
a Bible study with a group of
african-americans who were the very
model of respectability roof prayed with
them read the Bible with them thought
they were so nice then he shot them dead
leaving just one woman alive so that she
could tell the world what he had done
and why yet taken over our country he
said and he knew this to be true when
not even a full month after Dylan roof
gunned down nine African Americans at
Emanuel AME Republican presidential
frontrunner Donald Trump fired up his
silent majority audience of thousands in
July 2015 with a McCobb promise don't
worry we'll take our country back
no it's time instead that we take our
country forward into the future a better
future thank you
[Applause]
Wow
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you thank you
well I've got a new book coming out for
just a couple of questions so Jones on
the other side so if there's someone in
the audience with the question please
raise your hand and we'll try to get to
you
thank you
hi I'm that's it hello first off thank
you so much for coming to speak to us
and all of your inspiring and thoughtful
words I am a grad student with the
background in history and international
relations and as we see more of these
far-right movements acquaintance a
tional ism taking place in European
countries as well as here I wanted to
know if you could point to a single
cause or or even factor that's common in
white rage internationally as well as in
just America thank you so you know my
I'm a diplomatic historian right when I
said it wasn't it I think one of the the
key elements I'm just like the element
in the u.s. just as the element in
Europe has been the increasing diversity
of those areas and this feeling because
this is one of the mechanisms of white
rage is a narrative of a zero-sum game
that the only way that anyone else can
get will be in White's expense you know
so if I get it's going to be at your
expense if you get it's going to be that
zero-sum game it's a false narrative but
it is a narrative that has been plied
over and over and over by very ruthless
power-hungry politicians who know that
it works because all you have to say so
let me give you an example
and because in after the election box
did an interview in Kentucky I think it
was Whitley Kentucky where 62% of the
people were on Obama care and 80% voted
for Trump and so the reporters started
asking about what different
has access to health insurance mates for
you has it had any kind of impact on the
quality of your life and they were like
oh my gosh my husband's gonna get a
liver transplant a liver transplant and
another one was talking about I finally
have my diabetes under control because
I'm able to go see the doctor regularly
I mean so you know they're talking about
these aren't aren't small things this is
like life stuff
and as they're talking about it then the
reporter said well you know you voted
for Trump they're like yeah they're like
but you know they're gonna get rid of
the Affordable Care Act oh I heard them
but they don't mean that well you know
that the Republicans in Congress voted
nearly 60 times to try to dismantle the
stop you're scaring me and then comes
the zero-sum game yeah but you know my
premiums are going up and there are
those people who have better health
insurance than I do and they don't
deserve it you can your husband's get
ready get a liver transplant and who and
those people are getting something that
you rightfully believe you deserve and
they do not and that what they're
getting is at your expense that zero-sum
game is powerful we hear it we hear we
heard it in California when Pete Wilson
floated poplu prop 187 that said about
ensuring that immigrants children did
not have access to health care or to
education because it was costing us the
only way those immigrants could get
would be at our expense this is the same
kind of rhetoric you're hearing in
Europe this is the rhetoric you're
hearing in the United States
divide and conquer is powerful zero-sum
game is powerful we have got to be aware
of that so that we can begin to defuse
the power of white rage white rage is
absolutely destructive it is destructive
it is destructive to our democracy isn't
destructive to our educational system it
is destructive but it works politically
because we don't think in those terms so
that that is I see it is what's going on
I mean even a place like Denmark during
the Second World War
Denmark protected 93% of its Jewish
population think about that the King you
know in Denmark is occupied by the Nazis
and the king would not bow down and they
had worked out a system that when the
Nazis looked like they were going to get
too intense you know think about that
Nazis getting too intense but they had
triggers warnings for this and so they
had worked out a system where they were
ferrying people into the hospital to
look like they were patients they were
actually Jews that they were then
getting out of the country via a series
of Fischer fishing boats protected 93%
but right now in Denmark you have the
rise of a right-wing fascist group and a
lot of racial hatred coursing through
that society because you play on
people's fears white rage requires that
you put prey on people's fears about
what's going to happen to their home
their well-being their way of life it's
a standard text book professor Anderson
again I'm up here
again thank you very much early in your
presentation you said that white rage is
the reaction to african-american
achievement and much of what you've said
since then modified that but I think
that gives white rage too much of a
rational character
I wonder very much whether in the act I
mean in the absence of achievement to
the extent that us white people have
tried to keep achievement absent whether
white rage isn't still as furious I'm
having trouble believing in the
rationality of what you imply because
it's frightening because we expect
racism to wear sheet
we expect it to burn across we expect it
to look like Charlottesville that's the
kind of racism we know how to handle
that's the kind of racism we know how to
point a finger to that's the kind of
racism we know to go
but what do you do when it's sitting
there on the Supreme Court what do you
do when it's in the governor's mansion
what do you do when it's on the school
board and so the rationality let me kind
of walk you through the book coming out
after the end of the Civil War you have
a major advancement for African
Americans they are no longer property
they are human beings legal human beings
that is huge then with the 14th
amendment and the 15th citizens the
response to that was in tents yes
there's the violence but there is the
violence that has been sanctioned and
okayed without consequences by a
political and legal system and there are
a series of Supreme Court decisions that
systematically undermine the 13th
amendment the 14th amendment and the
15th amendment this is why we have to
have a civil rights movement in the
United States in the middle of the 20th
century after the US has defeated the
Nazis because there's all of this work
that was undone after the Civil War
because black people were citizens and a
series of policies were now coming
through to strip that freedom and strip
that citizenship from them
the great migration the next chapter
here Isabel Wilkerson
talks about it as being this is the
first step that the servant class ever
took without asking hmm oh she can write
and here you have this mass movement 10%
of the black population fleeing out
the South the South's response yeah you
had some violence also sanctioned by the
powers that be
but you had legislation coming through
like laws in Jacksonville forbidding
african-americans from leaving the city
to find a better job I'm telling you
right now imagine that in this
capitalist economy one of the things
that we understand in America is that
you will move for a better job
imagine a law a law so this isn't the
Klan writing this law this is the City
Council and signed off by the mayor and
enforce by the police that when black
people are at the train station
arresting them for vagrancy convicting
them of vagrancy and then auctioning off
their labor to the nearest plantation
owner they were stopping trains during
the first world war
I mean you know trees are absolutely
essential for being able to move war
materiel and personnel you know train
schedules are really tight they were
stopping trains in Mississippi to ensure
that black people did not leave this is
again not the Klan so as black people
are claiming their own sense of
self-determination the response was no
and when they went north because the
north is not the promised land I think
I'm gonna say that one again they ran
into redlining they ran into massive
discrimination and services and
employment you know where you've got a
two-tiered Union system coming out of
the plants out of in Detroit this
burg yes
that's the man he just said exactly so I
know I'm on it so you get these
structures and this is part of what it's
hard for us to wrestle with when I talk
about Brown yes again we see the Klan
but when we get over a hundred and one
US senators and congressional
representatives signing a manifesto
saying they will use every lever of
power that they have to stop Brown from
being implemented to stop black children
from getting access to a quality
education and let's be clear Plessy v
Ferguson of 1896 says separate but equal
the states were able to understand that
larger words separate equal equal that
word befuddled them and so they Emperor
implement it separate with a quickness
again this is the system that is doing
it this is a beginner you there are laws
on the books about separate Bibles when
you're swearing in in court you know
separate dogs cemeteries separate coke
machines just Brown when it was supposed
to break a Jim Crow the response from
the system gave legitimacy to the
violence but it also created its own
dynamic and systematically quietly
undermining the implementation of
anything that could really look like
through equality so that's why we've got
the Kerner commission report fifty years
later that is noting the systemic
inequality in terms of wealth in terms
of segregation that still haunts black
America in 2018 and when you think about
the election of Barack Obama
it was a scandal free administration he
inherited an economic system that was on
the verge of collapse
he had an absolutely recalcitrant
Congress that said its job was to assure
that he was a one-term president
and the response and I've heard well how
racist can America be how can this
really be because Obama was elected
twice have we heard that but in neither
in 2008 nor in 2012 that the majority of
whites who voted vote for Obama and that
is why when we're looking at the 2016
election what we see is that the only
candidate that the majority of whites
voted for who voted voted for Trump
there is something going on in this
system and so part of what has to happen
and that's one of the reasons I wrote
the book and so that we can begin to
have the real conversation not these
sound bites that were used to but that
we can get into the book I think a third
of the book footnotes so that we are
having an evidence-based discussion
about how we got here
[Applause]
dr. Andersson and I know that there are
probably 20 hands in the audience that
would love to ask a question now and I
would love to listen to you for for
quite a bit more time I can tell that
you are deeply engaged and I always love
what we have historian su come because
in reading your book and I will say that
there are over 80 80 individuals within
our community who read your book as a
part of conversations during MLK that in
reading your book
it was page after page of history that
we did not even for the most experienced
did not know and as a part of the
narrative we just say to you thank you
for coming here and engaging with us and
a power I've been getting texts from
individuals actually saying how much
they I had to leave but this was amazing
Wow thank you we have to say thank you
but you're always welcome
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so at this time let's let's thank her
once again
[Applause]
I forgot to mention our sponsor so it's
very important for me to mention our
sponsors the office of the president
cause dr. Trotter always thank you for
being faithful in terms of this Tim
Haggerty and the humanity science
humanities Scholars Program has been a
vital part of this and our Center for
student diversity and inclusion I just
have to say phenomenal in their support
efforts I have to do shameless plugs
okay before you leave out shameless
plugs because the International Film
Festival is happening this is week two
there the theme is faces of inequality
there have been some powerful powerful
film screenings happening on our campus
if you can find the time
please look that up come you sit in
audiences and engage and for students in
the audience because my comp my
colleague and friend here Holly hip it
still is here and in our rotation the
the Carnegie Mellon student experience
survey I press check your email please
please please go there students graduate
students undergraduate students and take
that survey because it helps to inform
our campus culture and climate and it's
something in which we take very
seriously your opinion matters and the
more that we can engage in these
meaningful conversations I think the
better we can be as citizens of the
Carnegie Mellon community and beyond
thank you again lovely have a good
evening
[Applause]